well dash cam video catches a close call  in oregon check this out a massive tree  collapsing onto a car with a department  of transportation worker inside and  while the recording shows how it all  plays out what the worker didn't know he  was in danger until the branch smacked  his windshield  i didn't see it coming i didn't see it  start to fall  i had no idea was happening until the  windshield shattered  as you can imagine his truck is totaled  though he walked away without any  injuries thankfully after calling for  help he says he got out and immediately  started working to clear the tree and it  wasn't until he watched the video later  that he realized just how lucky he was  very fortunate